so here's a question why am I talking
about education we have to look at how
we're setting up the next generation are
we doing enough to support young people
to thrive one of the things that I
personally struggled with when I went to
school is there was only one way to
judge a student which is how you
performed in your classes and I was
never the kind of person who was
motivated by grades I learned things at
school that weren't recognized or
rewarded I have a DD and so I was
terrible at paying attention terrible at
reading I'm really bad at reading so I
had to learn to ask good questions I had
to learn to go after class to talk to
the teacher I had to learn to go up to
my friends and say can you explain that
to me I became a good question ask her
and I became a really good listener the
solutions I found to the challenge is of
my own childhood became my strength as
an adult so are we doing that at school
now are we helping kids find solutions
to their own challenges which likely
will become their strengths as adults
when we talk about the what of Education
we're gonna talk about grades and
classrooms and we're gonna talk about
stuff that we generally talk about now
but if we talk about the why of
Education we're gonna ask an entirely
different questions we're gonna ask how
we can help children be more curious
we're gonna ask how we can help them
learn empathy we're gonna ask and try
and figure out how we can help foster
their passions rather than just help
them make a grade
so many people make a big point of the
number of jobs that exist today that
couldn't even conceive of 20 or 30 years
ago so of course the same will be 20 or
30 years from now and people will always
have to play a role there's gonna be a
lot of redefining what work looks like I
for one do not buy into the whole things
that AI and robotics is gonna replace
everything we like human interaction and
I think the education system can play a
much bigger role in preparing us to be
human we measure a student's performance
how well they perform on a test but we
have no metrics in school for the whole
person and we ignore their ability to
lead we ignore their ability to
communicate so I think when we teach
kids how to come together how to
organize how to have opinions I think
that that's what our future will hold
they will do the things we teach them
exams at school of course are important
but they're not all important we put so
much pressure on kids to make the grade
we treat education like a finite game
like school is the only thing but
education is our whole lives so how do
we use school to prepare a child to
continue to learn for their entire life
we want to be completely open to the
idea that we have more to learn I don't
think anybody goes to teaching college
and dreams of becoming a teacher because
they just want to teach math there's a
service component to becoming a teacher
that there's an element of giving back
to do something of higher purpose it has
nothing to do with the subjects they
teach but what is the underlying cause
that would inspire them to become a
teacher in the first place
administration's have to obsess with
creating an environment in which
teachers want to come to school in which
they feel that the administration has
their backs if I ask any school
administrator what's your number one
priority they're gonna tell me the
student it's completely wrong the
responsibility of leadership has nothing
to do with the results leaders are
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the results
administration serves the teachers and
teachers serve the students and when the
administration believes that the numbers
are everything the teachers will protect
themselves from their own leaders and
then the students will suffer
the things that I think are so good
about Generation Z is how open-minded
they are how accepting they are they
really are driven by inclusion and
acceptance I think that's a huge benefit
to the future of society I love that
they're an activist generation they're
not just hashtagging their discontent
their arranging rallies and they're
actually showing up
they're coming of age right now and
they're coming of age in a time of
stress in the world they're seeing
tension in their own countries
political divides that we have never
seen before and this is forming their
worldview I think some of the
liabilities that their generation has to
face and has to deal with is that we are
seeing increasing rates of addiction to
social media and suicide depression
anxiety and we're letting young people
grow up and just hoping that it works
out but why not teach them why not guide
how to interact with other human beings
what's appropriate and what's
inappropriate we can take responsibility
for teaching some of these skills I
think one of the most difficult things
about reforming the education system is
admitting that we have accountability if
we imagine a world that's different to
the one we live in now we all have to
take some responsibility that the future
leaders are going to come from the
schools that we have now and if we
better equip students now for what the
future will look like our world will be
better it's not just about the teachers
and the students every single one of us
has to play a role every single one of
us has to take responsibility for each
other
at every age especially kids were going
to school now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]